unter der eifel liegt ein gigantischer
vulkanische hotspot verborgen und der
bewegt sich aktuell
bisher ging man davon aus dass der
verborgene supervulkan unter dem lacher
sie schläft doch das war wohl ein irrtum
wie us fachleute jetzt herausgefunden
haben der aktuellen studie zufolge hebt
und dehnt sich der untergrund der eifel
stärker als er sollte besteht die nahe
zukunft die gefahr einer gewaltigen
eruption kriegs um zehn flugzeuge gibt
es dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts
los geht's noch nicht ganz
robbie williams hat sich jetzt auch als
anhänger von verschwörungstheorien
geoutet für uns in unserem wissenschafts
netzwerkes 1054 einer von ich würde mal
sagen tausenden gründen uns mit dem
thema verschwörungstheorien in einem
live-stream zu beschäftigen seit also
dabei und diskutiert mit am ersten juli
hier auf klicks um 20 uhr und jetzt geht
es mit einem anderen exklusiven thema
los herzlich willkommen clixoom gibt es
inzwischen auch auf die ohren und zwar
als podcast die links zu spotify und den
apple podcasts in unten in der video
beschreibung bereits einige erdbeben
serien hatten angedeutet dass sich im
untergrund der eifel etwas tut erst im
vergangenen jahr hatte ein deutsches
forschungsteam belege für ein aktives
vulkanisches system in der eifel
gefunden hierbei handelt es sich um die
region zwischen aachen koblenz und trier
unter dem lara sie hatten die fachleute
damals acht serien von niederfrequenten
erdbeben in einer tiefe von 10 bis 45
kilometern festgestellt jetzt haben
fachleute aus den usa weitere super
spannende belege dafür gefunden dass der
vulkan hotspot in rheinland-pfalz alles
andere als gut in ihrer aktuellen studie
schreibt das forschungsteam wenn wir
alle indizien zusammen nehmen scheint
klar dass sich unter dem herzen
nordwesteuropa etwas zusammenbraut
für ihre untersuchungen nutzten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
sehr umfangreiche datensätze von
tausenden gps messungen in
nordwesteuropa aus eine zentrale
forschungsfrage lautete wie stark hat
sich der untergrund in vertikaler und
horizontaler richtung bewegt hierbei
konzentrierte sich das forschungsteam
auf den zeitraum vom jahr 2000 bis zum
jahr 2019 durch die auswertung der gps
messungen konnte dann die hebung und
dehnung des untergrunds im bereich der
eifel im detail analysiert werden und
das ergebnis ist eindeutig und weist
eine überraschende anomalie auf dazu
conny crämer der an der studie beteiligt
war
die eifel ist das einzige gebiet in ganz
nord west europa in dem sich der
untergrund signifikant stärker bewegt
hat als erwartet das bezieht sich auf
einen großen teil des sogenannten
rheinischen schiefergebirges ein
mittelgebirge deutschlands dass sich
über die bundesländer hessen saarland
rheinland pfalz und nordrhein westfalen
erstreckt geografisch gesehen reicht es
sogar weiter bis nach belgien frankreich
und luxemburg nämlich und beinhaltet
sogar die agenten in diesem bereich also
konnten die us fachleute jetzt eine
anormal starke hebung identifizieren und
dies nach ansicht der fachleute
keineswegs mit dem langsamen zurück
fehlern der erdkruste nach der letzten
eiszeit zu erklären die forschenden
fanden heraus dass es sich um rund einen
millimeter handelt um den sich der eifel
untergrund pro jahr mehr hebt als er
eigentlich dürfte doch nicht nur diese
hebung lässt die fachleute aufhorchen
sie fanden auch eine zitat signifikanter
horizontale dehnung die von einem
strahlend förmigen muster der verkürzung
umgeben ist und genau diese kombination
aushebung und dehnung ist
außergewöhnlich und einzigartig in
nordwesteuropa
in der aktuellen studie ist von einer
anomalie die rede die sich nicht nur im
untergrund der eifel verbirgt sondern
bis ins östliche belgien in die
südlichen niederlande und bis nach
luxemburg reicht laut der fachleute ist
das ein starker hinweis darauf dass eine
so genannte mantel blume unter der eifel
aktives gemeint ist hier mit der auf
strom heißen gesteins materials aus dem
tieferen erdmantel besonders heißes
magma
hier also womöglich aus dem unteren
erdmantel allmählich wieder aufsteigen
in etwa 50 kilometern tiefe aber dann
ist schluss denn hier wird das super
heiße gesteinsmaterial von der
unterseite der festen erdplatte
aufgehalten
die fachleute sprechen von der
sogenannten lithosphäre so entsteht ein
gigantischer druck der sich durch
bewegung an der erdoberfläche bemerkbar
macht die aktuellen messungen legen also
nahe dass es sich um ein aktives system
handelt und der vulkan unter dem laacher
see keineswegs friedlich vor sich her
schwimmer diese these konnte dann
außerdem auch noch durch eine ergänzende
modell simulation gestützt werden hier
hat das forschungsteam die auswirkungen
eines mantel plumes rekonstruiert die
bewegung an der erdoberfläche die sich
bei dieser simulation ergaben sind den
gemessenen bewegungen sehr ähnlich heißt
also die bewegung die sich im untergrund
der eifel abspielen passen gut zu der
theorie
das mag man nach oben strömt für die
forschen lassen diese ergebnisse nur ein
schluss zu ein aufsteigender mantel
blume könnte die untergrundbewegung und
auch die beobachteten erdbeben musste
erklären doch was bedeutet das im
klartext wie groß ist das risiko einer
gigantischen eruption in der nahen
zukunft klar ist jedenfalls wenn es zu
einer eruption kommt könnte das
dramatische folgen haben vor etwa 13.000
jahren gab es in etwa den letzten
vulkanausbruch in dieser region und der
hat es in sich denn er stellte sogar den
ausbruch des vesuvs im jahr 79 nach
christus in den schatten das magma dass
der lara simultan damals heraus spuckte
hatte eine fläche entsprechend von 1500
fußballfeldern bedeckt und zwar 58 meter
hoch die asche aus der eifel rieselte
damals sogar noch in norditalien und im
südlichen schweden vom himmel kein
wunder denn die eruptionswolke gelangten
sogar in die stratosphäre also in etwa
30 kilometer höhe von wo der wind die
asche teilchen dann weiter verteilte in
der region selbst lag die asche bis zu
sieben meter hoch und sogar der rhein
war sogar verstopft und das hatte
dramatische folgen doch erst einmal
wurde der tag durch die eruptionswolke
zur nacht und alles leben erstickte
unter den meter hohen ascheschicht 'nen
bis zu drei tage lang
punkte der vulkan weiter aus dazu kamen
die glut lavigne 500 bis 600 grad heiß
die die vulkan hänge herab schossen und
sich rasend schnell ausbreitete ohne zu
übertreiben es war eine echte apokalypse
denn die glut lawinen wechseln sich mit
den eruptionswolke nab zudem senkte sich
die erdkruste ab und gräben brachen auf
es kam zur erdbeben erst wochen oder
monate später war das drama vorbei und
die landschaft rund um den vulkan waren
nicht mehr wiederzuerkennen stadt
wäldern sträuchern und tieren existierte
nur noch eine einzige mondlandschaft
doch der vulkanausbruch hatte auch
langfristige folgen denn wie schon
erwähnt wurde auch der nahegelegene
rhein bei anderen nach durch die
vulkanischen ablagerungen verstopft der
rhein wurde immer weiter aufgestaut und
es entstand ein riesiger see im oberen
mittelrheintal am ende bedeckte er wohl
mindestens eine fläche von 125
quadratkilometern
doch irgendwann war der druck des
wassers zu groß und der damm brach dabei
entstand eine art tsunami am rhein
die flutwelle war teils bis zu zwölf
meter hoch und vernichtete alles was
sich nicht schnell genug in sicherheit
bringen konnte die region dort das
sogenannte rheintal wurde größtenteils
zerstört zudem führte der gigantische
vulkanausbruch zu einer veränderung des
wetters sogar des klimas ausgelöst durch
die schwefelsäure partikel diese
entstehen wenn schwefeldioxid und
schwefelgase nach einem vulkanausbruch
in der atmosphäre mit wassertröpfchen
reagieren die mini partikel fungieren
wie eine art filter und verhindern das
sonnenlicht und wärme auf die erde
gelangt zudem schlägt sich der
wasserdampf an ihn nieder und es
entstehen wolken
der ausbruch des vulkans hatte somit die
folge dass es nicht nur kälter sondern
auch feuchter wurde dazu sagt der
vulkanologe hans ulrich schmincke wir
gehen heute davon aus dass über monate
bis jahre grosse niederschlagsmengen
anfielen
doch nicht nur in der eifel sondern auch
der kompletten nördlichen hemisphäre gab
es verheerende regenfälle welche
ereignisse sich wie und wann genau
damals abspielten war für die
wissenschaft lange zeit eine mysteriöse
rätsel für den tsunami am rhein konnten
beispielsweise erst in der jüngsten
vergangenheit wissenschaftliche beweise
gefunden werden und zwar an so genannt
aufschlüssen also besonderen regionen an
der erdoberfläche wo der untergrund zu
tage tritt und einfach analysiert werden
kann den ausbruch des laki vulkans
damals charakterisiert der
wissenschaftler hans ulrich schmincke
folgendermaßen die eruptionen des
laacher see wo kann es vor 12.900 jahren
die gewaltigste vulkanen explosion in
mitteleuropa in geologisch junger zeit
ist ein klassisches beispiel für eine
komplexe sogenannte clean iranische
eruptionen deren mechanismus im verlauf
der hauptphase des ausbruchs mehrfach
wechselte in der fachsprache ging es
damals also klinisch zu ähnlich wie beim
ausbruch des vesuv im jahr 70 nach
christus bei diesem mechanismus wechseln
sich in der hauptphase des ausbruchs
kilometer hohe eruption sollen mit
schnellen blut lawinen ab es handelt
sich also um äußerst exklusive ausbrüche
zurück zur aktuellen studie aus den usa
die fachleute raten dringend dazu die
prozesse in der eifel walter zu
beobachten
auch wenn die zahlen eher gegen eine
eruption in der nahen zukunft sprechen
denn auch der riesige vulkanausbruch im
lager see vor etwa 13.000 jahren hatte
sich wohl über jahrtausende angebahnt
hier hatte die befüllung der magma
kammer etwa 30.000 jahre lang gedauert
laut dem landesamt für geologie und
bergbau rheinland pfalz kam es in der
osteifel in den vergangenen 400 50.000
jahren durchschnittlich alle fünf bis
zehntausend jahre zu einem
vulkanausbruch der letzte wie gesagt vor
etwa 13.000 jahren doch die eifelregion
ist nur eines der beiden gebiete
deutschlands die vulkanisch gefährdet
sind
auch in der oberpfalz zwischen bayern
sachsen und tschechien gibt es schlafen
vulkane registrieren fachleute immer
wieder so genannte schwarmbeben
flüssigkeiten und gase gelangen dabei
aus dem untergrund an die oberfläche
forschende gehen von dutzenden vulkanen
in der oberpfalz aus und es gibt
zahlreiche hinweise darauf dass im
untergrund eine magmakammer brodelt
forschungsteams vom
umweltforschungszentrum leipzig halle
und des geoforschungszentrums potsdam
hatten rund zwölf jahre lang messungen
an der sächsisch bayerischen grenze
gemacht dabei spürten sie verräterische
gase auf die aufsteigen unter anderem
kohlendioxid und außerdem auch helium in
einer überraschend hohen
konzentration vergleichbar wie sonst nur
in vulkanisch aktiven regionen wie etwa
am ätna dafür dass hier eine riesige
magma kammer in etwa 30 kilometern tiefe
schlummert sprachen auch die
schwarmbeben in dieser region und gasen
das magma das durch spalten an die
oberfläche gelangt könnte diese mini
beben auslösen fest steht jedenfalls die
letzten vulkanausbrüche gab es in dieser
region vor 150 tausend jahren dazu
thorsten damen vom deutschen
geoforschungszentrum in einem interview
mit bayern 2 im jahr 2019
leider können wir nie genau vorhersagen
wann es zu einem ausbruch kommt aber die
zeiträume in denen wir als vulkanologen
und geophysiker denken sind relativ lang
10.000 jahre sind für uns kurze zeiten
seit wann es genau bereits unter dem
lara sie bebt können die fachleute nicht
mit letzter sicherheit sagen denn das
messnetz ist erst in der jüngsten
vergangenheit ausgebaut worden ein
wichtiger schritt in die richtige
richtung forschende kartieren nun das
magma vorkommen was allerdings eine
riesige herausforderung ist auch thomas
dreher vom landesamt für geologie und
bergbau in mainz rät dazu dass die
messungen in der eifel weiter ausgebaut
werden er ist sich mit den us fachleuten
einig dass nur so das genaue ausmaß
einer vulkanischen gefährdung beurteilt
werden kann zusätzlich zu dem bereits
bestehenden erdbeben messnetz ist es
nach ansicht der wissenschafts community
außerdem ein muss austretende gase zu
überwachen dazu thorsten damm in bayern
zwei interview
die eifel ist ein aktives vulkangebiet
da ist es heutzutage auf jeden fall
angebracht die überwachung zu überprüfen
zu überdenken und auch zu erweitert
insbesondere da auch wichtige parameter
heute nicht oder nur sehr unregelmäßig
gemessen werden in deutschland existiert
bisher noch kein vulkan
überwachungssystem was aber sinnvoll
wäre
vulkane sind nun wirklich keine
verschwörungstheorie man kann sich
überall auf der welt persönlich ein bild
davon machen aber warum gibt es so viele
verschwörungstheorien und das obwohl sie
gar nicht bewiesen oder sogar widerlegt
sind wir von essent 1054 das sind unter
anderem team von astor comics tv markus
von neugier zone martin von einfach
medizin der hat jetzt auch viel damit zu
tun und tom von dr wissenschaft wir
diskutieren live ihr bei pixum darüber
klickt also
auf diesen link und seid live dabei und
diskutiert mit uns über das thema
verschwörungstheorien ich bin sehr
gespannt auf das was da im chat passiert
also wir sind eigentlich auf alles
gefasst also bis dann bleibt dran